Yeah, you guessed it: another day, another
provocative Marvel rumor.
Citing their ever-mysterious inside sources,
We Got This Covered is now reporting that
Marvel Studios is considering DC leading light
Henry Cavill for the role of Captain Britain
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Now, as usual, it should go without saying
that this rumor needs to be taken with a whole
shaker of salt.
We Got This Covered don't exactly have the
best track record with Marvel news, and the
site's assertion that Cavill hasn't been contacted
about the role but is instead on a "wish list"
doesn't seem to mesh with Marvel's usual commitment
to total security.
Having said all that, however, Marvel has
actually already planted the seeds for Captain
Britain's arrival in the MCU with a brief
line in Avengers: Endgame.
It's hard to hear but when you have the closed
captions on you can see that the name Braddock
get mentioned.
Otherwise known as Brian Braddock, Captain
Britain first appeared in the pages of Marvel
comics all the way back in 1976.
And although you might assume otherwise, Braddock
is anything but a simple British copy of Captain
America despite the two sharing similar names.
A gifted young physicist, Braddock was working
on an experiment involving antimatter particles
when he had a fateful run-in with the supervillain
Reaver, who was intent on stealing the research
for himself.
Braddock sustained what would have been fatal
injuries when he crashed his motorcycle while
fleeing the scene but he was rescued by Merlin,
who gifted him with the legendary Amulet of
Right.
Yeah, that Merlin.
In addition to saving his life, the Amulet
of Right granted Braddock superpowers on par
with the mightiest of Earth's mightiest heroes.
He can fly, he's near-indestructible, he has
Daredevil-esque sharpened senses, and he can
even take on some of the Marvel universe's
most powerful heroes.
The only real drawback to all this is that
his magically-imbued powers wane if he ventures
outside the U.K. unless he wears his special
super-suit, of course.
Marvel die-hards have been fan casting Braddock
since at least 2017, when Kevin Feige name-dropped
the character as one that he'd like to explore
in the future.
On the press tour for Spider-Man: Homecoming,
the producer was asked about whether the studio
had plans to introduce Captain Britain.
We have discussed it.
There are a lot of actors that come in and
ask about that part, so we'll have to see."
Of course, it's likely that fan castings are
the real source of the Cavill rumor, too.
In September 2018, Twitter users raised the
possibility of Cavill playing Captain Britain
after it was reported that he had finished
playing Superman for Warner Brothers.
Mostly, this flurry of scuttlebut was based
around the fact that Cavill is square-jawed,
British, and looks good in a superhero suit.
And that should be enough, right?
But Cavill himself has done nothing whatsoever
to fuel these flames, and there are actually
a number of other British actors who have
expressed their own interest in playing the
role, too.
One of these is Simon Pegg, who told JoBlo
in 2018 that he had loved the character when
he was a kid and even had his own Captain
Britain mask.
Pegg has proven his action bonafides with
roles in the Star Trek and Mission: Impossible
franchises over the last few years, but he
did mention at the time that he feared he
may be too old for a major superhero role.
Considering he's currently 49 years old, that
seems to hold true.
Another name that keeps popping up in relation
to Captain Britain is Orlando Bloom, who threw
his name into the conversation during an interview
at around the same time as Pegg.
Heck, even Tom Hiddleston has expressed interest
in taking on the role, but that seems likely
to have been a joke, considering… well,
you know.
“Surprise.”
It's also worth noting that, while it was
widely reported last year that Cavill had
split from Warner Brothers and DC, this break-up
has never actually been officially confirmed.
In the wake of those reports, the studio issued
a statement saying that it has, quote, "a
great relationship and great respect" for
Cavill, and that "no current decisions regarding
any upcoming Superman films" had been made.
And while the franchise has been undergoing
an extensive recalibration as of late, it's
certainly not outside the realm of possibility
to think that Cavill could eventually return
to the role of Superman.
All in all, this Cavill rumor appears to be
highly suspect, and there's honestly a good
chance that it's all a bunch of malarkey.
Still, you never know.
And either way, you're best keeping your eyes
peeled because Brian Braddock could still
be popping up in the MCU sometime soon, whether
Cavill takes the role or not.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.